bazin
[Applause]
[Music]
for
me
[Music]
we're not aiming for any tour you and it's
new
[Music]
[Applause]
they are excluded sorry by the company
[Music]
I'm
no
it's just magnificent frankly we
've been fed up for two years we
know that we're fed up it's a
suffering of the people
can in addition  it's incomprehensible we
no longer understand anything when there are
laws but we no longer understand them
it's me I have all I understood
is that we are downright dictatorship
Nazi countries what frankly we see  the police
we feel attacked in this sense not protected
me I see her now I'm not afraid
because I'm not afraid here but I
know that something bad is going to happen to us
whereas before it was against us
saw them we were happy there are
more freedoms he was able to freedom we can no
longer say what we think a little more
do  re what we want to do we can
go where we want we almost have to
ask permission
here and we know she has I think
we will be expected to do it 2000
need more to leave
[Music]
[Music  ]
we want freedom
m
[Music]